finalement la virgule bonjour Antoine on
a donc appris hier que le groupe Wagner
interrompait ses recrutements et
suspendait ses combats en Ukraine ce
n'est plus aussi clair aujourd'hui mais
ça on dit long d'ailleurs sur
l'organisation et l'état de Wagner en ce
moment même c'est-à-dire qui hier vous
n'avez pas eu un communiqué de presse
quelque chose d'extrêmement clair ou une
conférence de presse comme on pourrait
avoir vous avez eu une communication par
l'une des nombreuses chaînes télégrammes
qui est un réseau social comme vous le
savez donc qui peut être utilisé sous
forme un peu de Twitter finalement et
bien pour dire que pendant un mois il
n'y aurait plus de recrutement de Wagner
il n'y aurait plus non plus de combat de
la part des combattants de Wagner en
Ukraine et puis finalement ce matin on a
des signaux contradictoires parce que
vous avez une autre chaîne télégram
également utilisée par Wagner qui en
utilise de nombreuses qui disent malgré
ce qui a pu être dit etc finalement nous
recrutons toujours si vous avez entre 22
et 55 ans si vous n'avez pas été
condamné pour viol ou pour crime ou pour
drogue et bien vous pouvez nous
rejoindre comme si finalement tout d'un
coup il y avait un peu de valeur dans le
recrutement de Wagner c'est un peu
ironique tout de même donc voilà donc
est-ce qu'il s'agit de combattants
potentiellement pour l'Ukraine ou au
contraire et bien pour la Syrie
peut-être ou pour l'un des pays
africains ou Wagner est implanté ça
reste à avoir en tout cas ce que l'on
sait de manière certaine et ça a été
confirmé par de nombreuses sources et de
nombreux enquêtes de d'organes
dépendants c'est qu'il y avait des
recrutements de Wagner après la
mutinerie encore ces derniers jours
encore vendredi dans de nombreuses
villes de Russie donc on recruté
toujours malgré ce qui s'était passé ce
qui peut paraître quand même un petit
peu fou sur le principe maintenant l'un
de ces recruteurs disaient oui oui nous
sommes toujours actifs mais je peux vous
dire une chose c'est que nous n'avons
aucune intention de rejoindre l'armée de
Vladimir Poutine vous savez que c'est
l'une des trois options qui a laissé le
président russe au combattant de Wagner
soit vous rejoignez l'armée soit vous
partez en Biélorussie rejoindre
trigogine votre chef soit vous rentrez
chez vous et on le veut plus entendre
parler de vous concrètement donc il faut
voir le président de la Douma donc
Parlement russe assure que il y a de
nombreuses personnes qui sont en train
d'être intégré à l'armée russe on se
rend compte qu'il y en a beaucoup aussi
qui vont en Biélorussie on va peut-être
voir la carte parce qu'il y a
manifestement trois camps qui sont en
train d'être construits en Biélorussie
notamment un avec un petit peu derrière
moi à 6 pots Vichy c'est une ville qui
est à 230 km au nord de la frontière
ukrainienne qui est à 100 km à peine de
Minsk et là vous avez deux photos
satellites qui sont extrêmement
intéressantes c'est une photo d'une base
militaire assez spartiate prise le 15
octobre elle est quasiment vide et bien
la même quinze jours plus tard
c'est-à-dire le 30 juin et bien vous
voyez tout ça a été construit et ce sont
pour manifestement les hommes de Wagner
et vous voyez que sont quand même pas
des petits pavillons de banlieue vous
avez des grands baraquements qui sont
quand même importants et donc voilà
c'est l'un des au moins un des camps et
il y en aurait à priori deux autres
maintenant on en a parlé ce matin un
député russe très impliqué dans les
questions de défense assure que Moscou
n'a absolument pas besoin de lancer une
nouvelle vague de mobilisation que vous
et en même temps se demande comment ils
vont faire sans Wagner qui était en
première ligne comme on le sait et on
apprend aussi que le Kazakhstan
reconnaît pour la première fois que la
Russie a tenté fortement de recruter au
Kazakhstan pour son armée régulière
voilà pour ces dernières manœuvres donc
il n'y a pas que l'aspect militaire
Antoine leur semble au démantèlement
pour Wagner oui parce que c'est un
immense groupe et pour pour faire simple
et rapide finalement vous avez un grand
groupe média qui s'appelle patriote
Media Group qui est en train d'être
démantelé le rédacteur en chef du site
principal ria fan et bien dit à
expliquer vendredi que tout le groupe
allait fermer c'est un groupe
extrêmement utilisé par Prigogine ces
derniers mois pour sa propre image vous
voyez le site
extrêmement puissant extrêmement aussi
critique envers les le ministère de la
défense notamment l'usine à troll a
également été démantelée et puis vous
avez la holding Concorde qui regroupe
une 400 400 entreprises environ qui
appartiennent à prix gojin en réalité
selon des médias russes et bien
plusieurs milliers de salariés donc tout
est en train de se déliter
progressivement merci beaucoup Antoine
pour le décryptage c'est la fin de ce
journal